Although the suffix tree approach has
reduced total run time and memory for read
mapping significantly, it still possesses a great
challenge in memory as the genome string is huge.
Can we reduce the genome string even smaller?
How can we compress the information in the genome
to allow efficient multiple pattern matching?
One way to compress the genome string is by
representing the number of repeats in numbers.
For example, given the genome string here,
instead of writing G 10 times, we can simply
compress the information and write it as “10G”.
Similarly, instead of writing "C" 11 times, we
can just write "11C". If the genome has a lot of
repeats like this, it would be easy to compress.
However, the problem is that the genomes don't
have lots of repeats like this. Another way
which can compress the information in the genome
is to use the Burrows-Wheeler Transformation.
Burrows-Wheeler Transform is
a way to sort and group data
so that similar letters are grouped together
so that it's easier to compress the data.
For example, the word “BANANA”. After
Burrows-Wheeler Transform you get the result
NNBAAA. Because the “As” are grouped together
it is now much easier to compress them.
How does it works? First, we keep moving the
last letter to the front to create a table.
For example, the word “BANANA”, we move the
last letter “A” to the front to make “ABANAN”.
We repeat this again and
move the “N” to the front.
We repeat this until the first
letter is at the last position.
The second step is we sort the table, starting
from a left column and we get “AAABNN”. If the
“A” on the first column are the same, then we
compare the second column where “B” comes before
“N”. Then the third column and fourth column and
so on and so forth. Then we have the sorted table.
The third step is to take the last column
as the Burrows-Wheeler Transform output.
In this case, the output is “NNBAAA”. Note that
the original string “BANANA” is at row number 4.
Why do we need to go through so many steps to
rearrange the letters, sort and create the matrix
table? One of the advantage of Burrows-Wheeler
Transform is that, it allows the genome strings
to be compressed and decompressed to get back
the original genome strings. For example,
if we use the regular sorting algorithm,
the word “BANANA” will turn into “AAABNN”.
The problem with this is that it is impossible
for us to retrieve the original words “BANANA”.
Burrows-Wheeler Transform is
different. We can reverse the
compressed information back to the original
words by just remembering the row number.
There are 5 steps to invert the Burrows-Wheeler
Transformed string back to its original message.
First, sort the output into alphabetical order.
For example, the output of Burrows-Wheeler
Transform of “BANANA” is “NNBAAA”. After sorting,
it became “AAABNN”. The second step is to add the
output column in front of the sorted column. Then,
in step 3, we sort both columns alphabetically.
After sorting, we add the Burrows-Wheeler
Transform output in front of the sorted column.
In step 4, we repeat step 2 and 3 again until
the length of the string has the same number
of the column. Finally, you will get the
original string “BANANA” in row number 4.
In summary, Burrows-Wheeler Transform is a
lossless compression algorithm that offers
both compression of the string and retrieval
of the original string whenever it is needed.